- [Voiceover] So Kim, we've been talking
about the run up to the Civil War.
We talked about the Compromise of 1850,
which angered a lot of anti-slavery
and abolitionist folks in the North.
As we get to the election of 1860,
you have Abraham Lincoln
getting elected.
And a lot of folks view that as a bit
of the final catalyst for the Civil War.
What's happening?
And is that accurate?
- [Voiceover] So, Lincoln is elected
as a Republican Party president.
This is the first Republican
Party president, ever.
And the real basis of the Republican Party
is an anti-slavery platform.
They really don't want slavery
to extend into the Western territories
that have been acquired
through the Mexican War.
So, they have been
making both an economic,
and to some extent, moral
argument against slavery.
So, when Lincoln becomes president,
the states of the South,
particularly the Deep South,
or this Cotton Belt area,
whose entire economic system
relies on slavery, they think
that they are under attack.
That Lincoln is going
to be coming for slavery
as soon as he gets a chance, as president.
- [Voiceover] And we're talking about
these states down here.
This is Texas, Louisiana, Mississippi,
Alabama, Georgia, South
Carolina, and Florida.
- [Voiceover] Right; so these are the real
cotton states, where slavery
is highly entrenched.
There, more than 50% of the population
is enslaved working on cotton plantations.
And it's making the elite people,
elite whites in the South, very wealthy.
Cotton is just the
backbone of their economy.
- [Voiceover] So what do they do?
Lincoln gets elected.
This is November of 1860?
- [Voiceover] That's right.
- [Voiceover] So what do they do about it?
They're afraid.
- [Voiceover] They're afraid that Lincoln
is going to do something about slavery.
So, over the course of this winter period,
this is in a period before we moved
the inauguration up to January,
so it used to be that presidents
would be elected in November
and not take office until March.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, we have here,
this Lincoln gets elected in November,
but then he doesn't get inaugurated
until March, over here.
- [Voiceover] So there's this long,
lame duck period where everyone
knows that a new political party
is going to be in power, a new president
is in power, but he's not in office yet.
- [Voiceover] And so
you have James Buchanan
sitting around; he's
still the president, but.
- [Voiceover] But, yeah,
his days are numbered,
and his power is pretty limited.
So, over the course of what they call this
Secession Winter, the seven states
of the Deep South get together
and they secede from the
Union, one after another.
And this includes South Carolina,
Mississippi, Florida, Alabama,
Georgia, Louisiana, and Texas.
They secede from the Union,
and they form what they call
The Confederate States of America,
which is, basically, almost exactly
the same as The United States of America.
Their constitution is based very
closely on the US Constitution.
But it guarantees the
existence of slavery.
It explicitly says that slavery
is allowed and protected forever.
And they elect Jefferson
Davis as their president.
- [Voiceover] So when they seceded,
for them it was clearly about slavery.
- [Voiceover] Right;
everything is about slavery.
They are concerned that Lincoln
is going to interfere with slavery.
They are afraid that because slavery
is being outlawed many other places
in the world, particularly
in the Western Hemisphere,
that, one way or another,
slavery's days are numbered.
And if they're going to
protect their livelihood
as slave owners and as cotton planters,
they're going to have
to form their own nation
to make sure that it's protected.
- [Voiceover] And James Buchanan
is officially president when
all of this has happened.
You have seven states
of the United States,
I guess they're not so
united anymore, leaving.
Is he just powerless to do anything?
- [Voiceover] Well, he tries a few things.
He was a very ineffective
president to begin with.
It's hard to be an effective president
when Congress is so divided over issues.
One thing that Congress actually does
before Lincoln is in office, and before
these states officially secede,
is they try what's called
the Crittenden Plan,
proposed by John Crittenden of Kentucky,
saying we will officially protect
slavery in the Constitution.
We will say that you can't outlaw
slavery in the South, and we'll even
extend this Missouri Compromise
line, which was sort of the official line
between North and South,
between free states and slave states,
all the way to the Pacific.
So, just so you know, Southern states,
we'll make sure that we
won't get rid of slavery.
- [Voiceover] So this
Crittenden Compromise,
this was kind of a last ditch effort.
Everyone's started to see
the writing on the wall.
These seven states, especially,
were very loose-in-the-socket.
- [Voiceover] And this was a last ditch
effort to keep them in the Union, perhaps.
- [Voiceover] Yeah,
and I don't want to say
it's too little too
late, but for the South,
they have seen the writing on the wall.
They have seen that this is going
to be their only opportunity to secede.
- [Voiceover] Lincoln got elected, and his
whole party is based
on being anti-slavery.
- [Voiceover] Right.
So, they want to get out
while the getting is good.
So that they can make sure
that slavery remains in their states.
- [Voiceover] All right, so
during this lame duck period,
the seven states, these Deep
South states, they secede.
Then Lincoln gets inaugurated.
He is now president.
And we're not really in the Civil War yet.
- [Voiceover] No, in fact, Lincoln's
inaugural address is very conciliatory.
We think of Lincoln as
being a really great orator.
And he certainly was, but
his first inaugural address,
if you read it, is very much
a plea to the South,
saying hey, really, I'm not planning
on outlawing slavery.
So, the anti-slavery platform that Lincoln
ascribes to is specifically about
not extending slavery to the West.
So he's saying I'm not in favor
of getting rid of slavery where it is,
so there's no reason
for you all to secede.
Come back, everything
will be situation normal.
- [Voiceover] And they don't.
- [Voiceover] No, as I said,
they've already seen
that this is their opportunity
to make sure that slavery continues,
by creating their own nation.
So, in the South, there are
a bunch of arsenals
and forts that belong
to the United States;
and most of these are taken
over by the Confederacy
when it becomes its own nation.
- [Voiceover] This is a
picture of one right here.
This is Sumter.
- [Voiceover] Right; so Fort Sumter
is right in Charleston Harbor.
And this is a Union fort,
or a United States fort,
that's holding out, basically.
They're running out of supplies,
they have tried to have supplies brought
in to them before, which
have been repelled.
- [Voiceover] They're holding out.
They're well in Confederate territory,
but they're still controlled
by United States soldiers.
- [Voiceover] Right; so, they do not
want to surrender this fort.
Lincoln lets the Confederates, the Rebels,
know that he wants to resupply this fort.
The Confederates instead
fire on Fort Sumter.
They start lobbing artillery at it.
Over the course of a day, they force
the Union forces in Fort
Sumter to surrender.
- [Voiceover] I guess this was the real
matchstick for the war.
But this wasn't the first tension.
- [Voiceover] No; obviously this had been
going on for some time.
- [Voiceover] Even in Buchanan's
lame duck period, there's
probably a little bit of tension.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, if
you want to be expansive,
you could say that this
tension is almost built into
the Constitution when they don't--
- [Voiceover] (laughs)
secede.
- [Voiceover] You got that right.
But especially, even post-secession
of these first seven states,
there are already some tensions,
especially if they're
taking over these forts.
Former United States soldiers are now
thinking about cutting off supplies
to current United States soldiers.
And then Fort Sumter, it sounds
like this was definitely the straw
that breaks the camel's back, so to speak.
- [Voiceover] Yeah,
this is the tinder box.
And I think it's maybe intended
to be a tinder box on both sides.
Because Lincoln wants to be sure
that if there's going to be a war,
the North isn't going
to fire the first shot.
They want to make sure
that this is the South's decision.
It can be blamed on
them if it needs to be.
- [Voiceover] This is a pattern you see
throughout history, is
that no one at least
wants to, officially, be the
person to fire the first shot.
They often look for a good reason
to fire the first shot because
they want to get into war,
but everyone wants
to have the moral high ground.
- [Voiceover] Right; and in the South,
they are looking to make sure
that this is kind of a
morale building moment.
When they fire on Fort Sumter,
they're firing on a federal fort, right?
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] In any circumstances,
that's going to bring on war.
And they're hoping that if they can
kind of get this fire started,
then these four other slaveholding
states, or actually eight other
slaveholding states, in the South
are going to join the effort.
And that's pretty much
exactly what happens.
So, after they fire on Fort Sumter,
the fort is surrendered
to the Confederacy.
Lincoln says, okay, you want
to start a war, we got a war.
He calls for 75,000 troops,
volunteers to put down the insurrection.
He calls them for a 90-day service period,
which tells you how long
they thought this was gonna last.
After Lincoln has asked for this army,
four more slaveholding
states in the South secede.
And that's Virginia, the
most important of these,
it's gonna be the real
battleground of the Civil War.
- [Voiceover] Today, we'd
consider that West Virginia
and Virginia, but that
was Virginia back then.
- [Voiceover] Right; Virginia, Arkansas,
Tennessee, and North Carolina
also join the Confederate
States of America.
And the war is on.
- [Voiceover] Fascinating.